welcome back let's get more now on news
breaking in the last hour and the
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
has been jailed for
two and a half years a moscow court
decided he's violated
probation terms he was arrested last
month after recovering from a nerve
agent poisoning
he blames on the kremlin countries
including the uk
the us and germany have already
condemned
navalny's jailing vladimir ashkerkov is
an ally of
navalny and a director of the
anti-corruption
foundation and he joins us now thank you
for being with us first of all what is
your reaction to the sentence
well the sentence was uh not unexpected
but
it still came as a shock that the same
people the authorities who ordered
poisoning of alexis navalny a few months
ago
they would on totally falsified charges
put him into prison how will
people on the streets react do you think
there have been these protests
over the last um weeks uh
how how will they react do you think
i think the anger on the streets will
only increase
it was such a blatant mockery of justice
what were witnessed over the last uh two
weeks when navalny came to russia
was uh detained in a makeshift
court and the decision today
it's really i think uh
is will get many many people uh agitated
and we'll see
continuation of protests and turmoil uh
more so than what we've seen over the
last two weeks
i mean he went back of his own accord he
he knew he would be arrested he may well
have known that he would get a prison
sentence
what um what would be legally the next
move is there is he likely to appeal
of course he will appeal it will take
about uh from one month to
two months and and i mean
the chances of being successful um with
that appeal given how the authorities
seem
to want to quieten him what do you make
of that
well the decisions is not made in the
courtroom it's made in the kremlin and
in the same place where the decision to
poison him was made
the decision to start new proceedings
against him
and the decision that we have seen and
witnessed today
to put him in jail for two and a half
years
and vladimir have you managed to speak
to him
recently at all i spoke with him
a few days before he boarded the plane
to moscow but not after
he was uh in already in russia and
he was immediately in detention and
judging from people you may have spoken
to
who have been with him what's his state
of mind what is he
um how is he well we have seen the video
footage from today's court hearing
um it was uh really heartbreaking when
the verdict was announced he was
drawing a heart uh aimed at his wife
julia
who was there in the courtroom uh he
maintains good spirits and
these awful circumstances and
he knows that the game is long and
he knows that this sentence is a sign of
weakness
of russian authorities when with all
their power they're sentencing one male
to jail
and he knows that he will prevail
eventually and how worried do you think
president
putin is by the protests that are
happening in in well in many russian
cities
i think it's irrational but we've seen
by the presence of police in
many big cities in russia by the severe
beatings
by the fact that over 7
000 people were detained
uh last sunday during the massa
protests and the protests were totally
peaceful
not a single policeman was harmed so
i think he is quite concerned and he
feels that he is vulnerable
and they're clearly coordinated the pro
protest are you helping
coordinate them and how are they being
coordinated
um well of course our organization we
have branches in different russian
cities
so we take the lead to coordinate
where people gather and what's the route
but
you know no coordination can bring
tens of thousands of people to the
streets it's uh
when people feel injustice when people
feel offended by this mockery of justice
they
naturally take to the streets
is there one problem that the
the protests could end up playing to an
extent into president putin's
hands in that many russians fear
chaos and instability and putin i
suppose could portray
you know the chaos as being as a result
of protests
the chaos and instability that may
follow are totally
the result of the actions of the
authorities
they could have handled this much more
uh subtly and they could have led
the political opposition to have
presence in the uh political system
but they decided to close all the leads
uh on the cattle and uh inevitably it's
gonna
boil and and and blow up and uh
unfortunately
uh there will be chaos because of the
actions of the authorities
okay just a minute left i mean do you
seem to suggest that you you fear a
stronger crackdown
or greater repression
it's possible we have seen escalation of
violence over the
last few uh days over the last two
protests
on the last weekends uh we don't know
what's gonna happen but for sure the
level of discontent
uh among the people of course is gonna
only grow
okay uh vladimir shirkov we appreciate
your time i should just ask you
i mean do you last 10 seconds i mean do
you fear for your own
safety your own life i feel much safer
in london than i
uh was in moscow my heart goes to people
who are now
detained and beaten in russia and
are sentenced like alex say to uh long
sentences
but we know that russian security
services they
if they decide something they can make
assassinations in any part of the world
so yeah i'm always cautious
okay well vladimir shirkhoff thank you
very much for joining us